خطا صدفه جزيره بالي في اندونيسيا قمه
مجموعه العشرين في ظل التوتر في بحر جنوب
الصين ومضيقي تايوان اضافه الى الحرب في
اوكرانيا ورغم سعي الرئيس الاندلسي لحضور
الرئيسين الروسي والغيره الاوكراني قمه
بالي الى انه باتا من المؤكد انهما لا
يشارك حضوريا ومن المقاري ان تناقش القمه
القضايا عده ابرازها الصحه والغذاء
والطاقه وتحول الرقمي
عبد الحق ناصر ما الذي ينتظره الصينيون من
هذه القمه بين
الرئيس الصيني
بالتاكيد عبد الصمد الصينيين ينتظرون ان
تتحسن العلاقات بينهم وبين الولايات
المتحده على الرغم من انهم يعوون تماما
مدى ااا يعني ااا
قوه الخطاب الامريكي تجاه بعض القضايا
الرئيسيه التي يعتبرونها خطوط حمراء خاصه
فيما يتعلق بقضيه تايوان وقضيه اا التنميه
الصينيه التي
ينظرون الى الولايات المتحده بانها تسعى
لحرمانهم من هذه التنميه وذلك من خلال
العقوبات المستمره منذ فتره ضد مشروعاتهم
التنمويه خاصه في قطاع همم التقنيه
الفائقه والعاليه لكن هناك يعني همم اعمال
بان تحقق هذه القمه نتائج على الاقل يعني
تفضي الى بدء في همم حوار جاد بين الصين
والولايات المتحده
والصينيين ذهبوا الى هذه القمه الرئيس سجن
بين هذا اول لقاء له مع جو بايدن منذ
تواليه اداره البيت الابيض قبل عامين وهي
همم السادسه بعد خمس لقاءات
افتراضيه تمت عبر تقنيه الفيديو تم خلالها
مناقشه العديد من القضايا لكن الجميع هنا
في الصين يتطلع الى هذه القمه كونها ستكون
وجها لواجب ان يصل الجانبان الى همم
وسطى حسب التعبير همم الصينيين بان يلتقي
الطرفان في الوسط لحل قضايا الخلاف بينهما
ايضا يذهب الرئيس الصيني السجن الى هذه
القمه بعد همم اسابيع من انتهاء مؤتمر
الحزب الشيوعي همم الصيني الذي انتخب او
انتخبه الرئيس سجن
ولايه ثالثا امين عام للحزب الشيوعي
الصيني مما يمهد له لرئاسه البلاد عند
انعقاد قمه اا او عند عند انعقاد جلسات
البرلمان في اذار القادم وبالتالي همم
يتمتع الان الرئيس الصيني
بالسلطات اكبر ربما تساعده على الوصول الى
همم اتفاقات مع الرئيس